dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly say here in this
piece of work we are interested in
creating a 3d virtual tour for an
apartment however for this apartment no
3d information is available instead the
input for the algorithm is something
that we can obtain easily in this case a
2d floor plan and a set of images that
we shot in the apartment from this
information we would create a 3d floor
plan that is not only faithful to the
real one in terms of geometry but the
photos with the correct viewpoints are
also to be assigned to the correct walls
in order to accomplish this one has to
overcome a series of challenging
problems for instance we have to
estimate the layout of each room and
find the location of the camera in each
of these images also to obtain high
quality solutions the goal is to extract
as much information from the inputs as
possible
the authors recognized that the floor
plans provide way more information than
we take for granted
for instance beyond showing the
geometric relation of the rooms it can
also be used to find out the aspect
ratios of the floor for each room the
window to wall ratios can also be
approximated and matched between the
photos and the floor plan this
additional information is super useful
when trying to find out which room is to
be assigned to which part of the 3d
floor plan beyond just looking at the
photos we also have access to a large
swath of learning algorithms that can
reliably classify whether we are looking
at the bathroom or a living room there
are even more constraints to adhere to
in order to aggressively reduce the
number of physical configurations make
sure to have a look at the table for
details there are lots of cool tricks
described there as always there is a
link to it in the video description for
instance since the space of possible
solutions is still too vast a
branch-and-bound type algorithm is
proposed to further decimate the number
of potential solutions to evaluate and
as you can see here the comparisons
against ground truth floor plans reveal
that these solutions are indeed quite
faithful to reality the authors also
kindly provided a data set with more
than 200 full apartments
with well over a thousand photos and
annotations for future use in follow-up
research works creating such a data set
and publishing it is incredibly
laborious and could easily be a paper on
its own and here we also get an
excellent solution for this problem as
well in a separate work the authors also
published a different version of this
problem formulation that reconstructs
the exteriors of buildings in a similar
manner there's so much to explore the
links are available in the video
description make sure to have a look in
case you're wondering it's still
considered a crime not doing that I hope
you have enjoyed this episode and I find
it so delightful to see this
unbelievably rapid growth on the channel
earlier I thought that even two would be
amazing but now we have exactly eight
times as many subscribers as one year
ago words fail me to describe the joy of
showing these amazing works to such a
rapidly growing audience this is why I
always say at the end of every episode
thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time
[Music]
you